you
a study after study comes out and says
that rest relaxation recharging is
critical to keeping employees creative
and engaged and yet I'm surprised by how
many businesses don't set up their
policies in a way that really support
that I can feel the difference in myself
when I take adequate time to sleep to
rest to actually take vacation every now
and then versus when it's just go go go
and so in terms of policies that I've
seen be effective obviously there's a
fair amount of debate right now within
the technology community in particular
around unlimited vacation because I
think that it can be used for good or
for evil based on your situation the for
good is more obvious these are companies
that tell people look we need you to get
your work done we need you to behave in
a responsible manner but we're not going
to be tracking your vacation time so if
you need a Friday here a Monday there a
half day here a week there go do that
often the best companies these days are
giving guidelines as well so they're
saying look most people take at least
two full weeks plus you know for 28 days
throughout the rest of the quarter etc
whatever it is companies that have taken
it another direction we've seen
companies where unlimited vacation means
you can have it whenever you want it but
don't you dare have it which i think is
incredibly counterproductive both for
retention and just honestly for
productivity and creativity and
engagement some other creative
strategies that we've seen I'm a huge
fan of sabbaticals so sometimes that
larger companies have done these for a
while we're starting to see them among
smaller companies we actually just
instituted one of the muse for us it's
after five years of working with the
company we provide either a month paid
for an employee to go do whatever they
want or if somebody for whatever reason
would prefer it they also have the
option of two weeks plus a stipend they
don't member exactly what it is but the
idea is it would be enough to take a
family on a really nice trip and the
idea is that five years is a long time
it's a really long time and I think as
an employer I mean if you want to thank
and honor and respect that commitment
that someone is given to you what better
way to do that then
really give them a chance to take a
break so few of us get that in our day
to day and sometimes people will leave
jobs just to have a period of time and
so I think being able to do that and
still go back to a company that you love
is really powerful I know Intel a while
back used to do that every seven years
just having something that I think
acknowledges the relationship between a
company and an individual a human and
and allows them kind of celebrates them
for who they r gives them the space and
time to engage in other commitments
family travel whatever it is i think is
really powerful and again that's not
going to be feasible for everyone but i
think at the heart it it starts with for
a manager for an employer really
thinking what is the best that i can
provide right now and how do i really
encourage my team to take time off so
that when we're tackling a big problem
we're all fresh and we're all really
excited about about figuring it out you
know I think where we're moving away
from the workplace where people have to
be butts and seats from nine to five and
if they need to leave for a doctor's
appointment or because their kid is sick
or maybe they're just there they're
having a really challenging day and it
would be better for them to leave and
finish up that work later and I think
that it's really important to support
your employees and being whole humans
and do your best to let them do that and
so yes if that means that there may be a
little bit of personal life that
intrudes into work you know we're all
connected to our smartphones 24-7 and
for many people work in truths to the
personal life obviously i'm not talking
about every job there are roles for
which exceptions are necessary or which
people's presence is mandatory but i
think when you can really allow your
team the trust and the freedom to manage
their work and their personal life and
trust that as long as they're getting
their work done the fact that there may
be a small amount of blending isn't
necessarily a bad thing and i think
ultimately can make can make people that
much more committed to you as a company
because you understand that they they
are whole people they have other lives
it's that flexibility that i think we
see as a very strong driver for a lot of
um both people who are desiring deciding
what company to go to and also obviously
retention whether to stay or whether to
take an offer from a recruiter a former
colleague or somebody else